[Music]
foreign
so time for the Press preview it's our
first look at what is on the front of
Monday's papers and this evening we'll
see what's making the headlines with
political journalists Sophia slay and a
political commentator Benedict Spence
great to see you both we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at some of
the papers for you including the Metro
you're out of order reads its front page
as it leads with the apology from senior
cabinet minister Michael Gove for what
he called the indefensible party gate
video
the guardian also features the video and
says Rishi sunax attempts to move on
from Boris Johnson have been set back
with police considering the footage
while the Daily Mail leads with the
mortgage crisis as experts urged the
bank of England to pause interest rate
hikes to ease the impact on homeowners
the eye also follows this story with the
headline Banks told to ease soaring cost
of mortgages as rates rise
the times looks ahead to an expected
tightening of rules for migrants so
britons can be the priority on Council
house lists
the Ft International reports that
AstraZeneca has drawn up plans to break
out its China business and list it
separately in Hong Kong to shelter the
company against mounting geopolitical
tension
and the star reports on claims that
Brewers are lowering alcohol levels to
save money
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see it on screen during
the program check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
discussing them and I'm joined by
political journalists Sophia slay and
also the political commentator Benedict
Spencer good to see you at the end of
this weekend a warm and muggy weekend
it's been as well let's start with the
front of the Metro shall we following on
from the mirrors exclusive remarkable
exclusive uh this morning this video of
uh partying staff despite the the covid
rules at the time Sophia what what do
you make of the Fallout from it
yeah I mean it's still rumbling on isn't
it I mean this is the party gate shows
no sign of going away yet I mean Michael
Gove was out on the uh Airwaves this
morning and um apologized quite
willingly he was very forward I must say
in his apology
um he was confronted with that video on
a few TV shows um and he sort of
strongly condemned
um the the visuals the the people
dancing and things like that and he was
he was very strong he sort of said it
was unacceptable and indefensible I mean
I think when he was confronted with that
footage what else can you say really
um it's it's a terrible look
um to be fair I mean we did know about
this event it has been reported before
um widely but we only had a photograph
of this event before and I think the
video in in the age we now live in was
really damning and really really
powerful and I think also what was
shocking about it is it it's it's the
the voices in the background people
chatting and there is an acknowledgment
that essentially they probably were
bending the rules and you know this was
in conservative Campaign Headquarters so
although you know Michael Gove
apologized for this this morning I don't
think this is going to go anywhere
anytime soon I think Rishi sunak will
probably face uncomfortable questions
about this
um just when he he doesn't want
uncomfortable questions as well when
he's got a lot on his plate right now
yeah and Benedict there's still lots of
sort of unanswered questions aren't
there um one of them is why is this only
come out now when we have seen stills
from this party we know the police
investigated it at the time and yet for
some reason the video is only just
emerged is the timing of that um at all
interesting given that it comes just
after the publication of the report and
before tomorrow's Vote or is it
coincidental what do you think it might
be
I mean I do think that it's something
that's possibly been held back with the
intention of elongating the pain
or the government yeah especially in the
sort of the post Boris Johnson era I'm
sure that there will be plenty of people
who will want it to be the uh people
that are reminded that it is not just
Boris Johnson who was responsible for
what was going on behind the scenes that
there were other members of the
government who have perhaps moved on or
moved up or moved around since then and
it's sort of you know it's trying to
continue and eke out the pain uh I don't
think it'll necessarily have as much
impact though as it might have had
earlier on I think you know if you sort
of look at the footage and people
dancing around and I think they're
singing fairy tale of New York or
something like that I think if it had
come out a few months ago or at the time
I think it would have probably prompted
a really quite visceral and angry
response
um a little bit closer to the fact I
think now though we've had
Furious Benedict or maybe people are
Furious that that these people are
flouting the rules whilst they were
being told they couldn't have Christmas
with loved ones or whatever
no I don't think people have been
curious I think people have been Furious
I think they have now just come come to
accept that there was so much
misbehavior going on that it has now
been priced in I think that it is
something that would have had a lot more
impact if it had come out months ago
actually I think it is now sadly uh
probably going to be the sort of thing
where a lot of people shrug their
shoulders and they go well yeah we all
know that the government were not doing
you know members of the government
members of the conservative party were
not behaving as they should have done I
think that's the thing this is a very
sort of I think this has been poorly
timed actually if it has been held back
because I think it could have done a lot
more damage earlier on now I think given
the Boris Johnson has left and we've had
all the drama I think it's almost just
like a sort of an echo of the entire
period I think people are still still
annoyed about it but I don't think it's
going to hurt Rishi sunak all the
tourists any more than this whole story
has already done ultimately I think that
we've had that moment where it was
incredibly damaging and now that pain is
priced in what what do you think about
that Sophia would you agree with that
um a bit of both really I think for the
people whose lives were wrecked by kovid
who lost loved ones who were not allowed
to be with loved ones as they were
passing away
um this is these kind of incidents and
stories are going to always be extremely
painful for them and you know think
about those nurses and doctors and
carers that we were out clapping for
every night you know the ones on the
front line desperately trying to save
lives I mean where I probably would
agree with Benedict is that you know the
context of this it was I think it was
during the tier system and
um what a confusing time that was
obviously not remotely um excusing their
behavior or anything like that because I
was at home trying to figure out all of
these rules myself you know I remember
elderly people I knew that were
terrified of sort of Crossing tier
borders to go to their normal
Supermarket because they weren't sure if
it was within the rules or not or if
they were going to get in trouble and
restaurants on one end of one road that
were closed because they were in the
wrong tier and a restaurant at the other
end was allowed to be open it was it was
a really mad time to be honest and not
that I'm excusing their behavior or
anything like that but I think I think
we should just I mean sort of like
Benedict's point is is quite valid that
you know times have moved on the people
that are going to be angry are going to
continue to be angry and hurt by this
um and I sort of question as well is you
know is this a useful time for uh you
know use a good use of police time
looking into this now and that that's
another issue that's sort of been raised
as well because the police are now sort
of re-looking at this did or looking at
this video now it's emerged so I'd have
questions over is that is that a good
use of police time at the moment you
know looking at all these old covered
laws that are not in place now yeah
interesting point well let's have a look
at the front of the Guardian
um they're still angry about it their
headline pressure on sunac as met please
consider Lotus party gate video
um I mean whether or not this is going
to have much impact
um Benedict what is potentially going to
have a big impact are these four now
four by-elections that are coming up um
plus of course Boris Johnson with his
column in the mail he says he's not
going to talk about politics but you can
bet he'll he'll uh he'll lob a few
grenades in over the next few months
well that's the thing that's why I do
think that this this whole sort of yeah
and it is a fiasco it has been appalling
uh party Gates and everything that sort
of went on around it it has done a lot
of damage I do think we've now moved on
to slightly more if you like acute
sources of pain certainly for the
government I think that you know the key
things
um are going to be around things like uh
cost of living whether or not people
feel poorer at the end of Russia sunax
time in office than they did uh before
these are the sorts of things that are
going to really I think stick the boot
in for him and I think we are going to
see that reflected now in these
by-elections of course this has all
happened part well not all of it partly
as a result of Boris Johnson who was of
course brought down by party gates at
least in part
um but you know what we're going to see
now I think is a barometer of just how
irritated people are uh with the
government now it is handling many
things not just partying you know it can
be immigration it can be energy policy
it can be anything you want we're going
to see what people really think and the
key thing of course here is a lot of
these are several of them are pretty
safe Tory seeds so if you see sort of
large majorities being hammered down
quite a lot that could be cause for some
real alarm Bells I think for Richie
sunac so I think it is a bit of a
headache we do need to remember he does
still have a sizable majority he's going
to still have a surgical majority for
some time what he can do with that I
don't know at this moment in time but
far more than the local elections that
we had recently this is I think going to
be an opportunity for a lot of Voters to
give the Tories perhaps rather than
Russia sunak himself a proper slapping
so I I we wait with baited breath to see
just how bad those could be yes uh
interesting isn't it and you're talking
about all the various issues uh facing
the government at the moment let's turn
to one of them
um mortgage rates front of the Daily
Mail I think it's the the 13th
consecutive increase we're expecting on
on Thursday uh Sophia the base rate set
to go up from 4.5 to 4.75 possibly even
more than that but the male is saying
that the bank are being told to to wait
because it's just going to be so painful
for members of the public coming off
fixed rate or on on variable rates
um I mean they make a very good point it
will it is it's already very very
painful for some people that have
already had to remortgage recently and
send their rates or it's going to get
even worse and you know sort of
listening some of the case studies on
the news
um today
um you know people are really really
worried about how they're going to pay
pay their mortgage they're already
struggling with bills with paying for
food the price of everything is going up
but these more more these mortgage rates
I mean the the amount they will go up by
it's gonna really hurt people in them in
you know their monthly payment we're not
talking a few pennies here we're talking
hundreds of pounds that are hitting
families at a really difficult time and
to be frank it's it's an absolute
nightmare for millions of homeowners who
are going to have to remortgage
um you know already having to pay
hundreds into their monthly payments I
mean it's a bit of a it's a bit of a
contentious issue politically
um I know Jeremy Hunt has backed the
bank of England and says you know
there's no real alternative to raising
interest rates it's what needs to be
done to bring down inflation and there's
also you know obviously the The Daily
Mail wants the bank of England to do
something and you know not
um raise it but there's also another
debate raging uh people that want to see
the government step in and help people
with their mortgage payments
um you know I think that's sort of come
on the back of huge interventions over
the past a few recent years sort of
energy bills covid furlough and things
like that so there's a big I mean it's
it's stinging people real people in
their wallets right now and it's also
sparking a huge political debate and I
think this is going to really dominate
this week's discussion and certainly
with MPS and you know you're already
ordinary man and woman outside of
parliament yeah um it's a it's a very
tough one isn't it front of the eye it's
the same story Banks told to help ease
soaring costs and mortgages as rates
rise I mean is there an argument do you
think Benedict to to pause arise even if
it's just for a few weeks or is that
going to prolong the pain in the long
run I think it I think it will just end
up prolonging the pain this is going to
be a dreadful situation for a lot of
people but I don't really see how else
we can go through it I mean the part of
the problem of course is with people
suggesting that maybe the government
should step in is again we're all going
to end up shouldering that burden down
the line with interest it doesn't really
solve any of the problems that we have
um you know trying to get sort of major
government interventions and things like
this of course an open-ended guarantee
on Energy prices was what partly did for
Liz Truss I'm not sure what it would do
for Russia to sort of swoop in and say
it's all right I'll pick up the slack
and you know potentially millions of
people's mortgages over the next couple
of years that could be very bad but it's
something of an existential crisis for
the tourists because a lot of the people
who are going to be really hurt by this
are young people young families people
who've just got on the housing ladder or
haven't been on it for very long
relatively the sort of people at the
conservative party ought to be appealing
to and we can see from pulling across
the board are just not enamored with a
party at all they feel they do feel that
their living standards have gone down
substantially it's been very difficult
to get onto the housing ladder and now
it's about to be very difficult for a
lot of them to stay on the housing
ladder it's you know a curious sort of a
crush of uh potential Tory voters who
are being driven away from the party
because of the situation that they find
themselves in but the country can't
really afford them right for the
government to come in all guns blazing
and try to bail them out this is a
result of many many issues but one of
the main thing is it's about housing
policy you don't build enough houses
you're always going to have these sort
of crunches prices going up so even if
we didn't have these interest rate
issues yeah that we were always heading
for a bit of a bottleneck when it came
to the housing market in this country
yeah Sophia you're uh agreeing with that
just a final thought from from you as
the eye uh mentions here uh it's also
very difficult for people to see
mortgage rates going up but savings
rates aren't going up at the same same
extent
yeah I mean it's it's a bitter pill all
round at the moment isn't it it's it's
we're all I mean it's not just a pinch
it's a real big nip in terms of the cost
of living crisis at the moment for
everyone from from the poorest to those
that are quite wealthy and the jams you
know they're just about managing
everybody is feeling it front page of
the times uh Sophia interesting story
this ministers apparently concerned
according to the paper that the rules
aren't strict enough about who gets
Council housing priority
um Coming of course at a time when net
migration is at record levels
yeah this is um a seriously uh
eye-catching story on the front page of
the times I think it's a classically
sort of polarizing
um eye grabbing story
um essentially sort of they're saying
that the ministers want to prioritize
British Nationals so that they sort of
shoot up the the council housing ladder
um and
um sort of migrants would be like well
immigrants sorry would be pushed further
down
um it doesn't say which department the
story has come from or which ministers
are looking into this my suspicion but
it would be Michael ghost Department
which is in charge of housing um and it
it feels quite Michael gove-esque he's
very good at eye-catching
um media grabbing stories and so I
wouldn't be surprised if it comes sort
of from from his Camp I think uh I mean
the language and rhetoric in this story
is it would will be quite polarizing
um that they you know government Source
uses the phrase you know that they want
to stop migrants jumping the queue
jumping the queue for housing and that's
certainly going to you know infuriate
and upset some people certainly on the
left and I think even
um some conservatives on the left of
their own party won't like that kind of
language but you know they the
government clearly thinks that this
story is going to chime with migrants
with um voters sorry and they've clearly
singled out sort of migrants and small
boats as an issue as a sort of visual
that they want to campaign around
um ahead of the next general election I
mean I think sort of reading through the
story I would sort of gently point out
that um you know this story points out
that one in ten on the social housing
lists are non-uk Nationals and you know
there's there's currently 1.2 million
households on the waiting list for this
one point and that's not 1.2 million
people that's households and so it's my
big question surrounding this story is
um what social housing you know where
are they getting this social housing
from you know there's 1.2 million
households on this waiting list for a
reason you know the migrants the
immigrants are a very small proportion
of This 1.2 million households
um the real issue here
um is there's not enough homes being
built which is exactly which of course
is exactly the point Benedict was making
when we went into the break uh wasn't it
that we just don't have enough enough
housing stock Benedict what do you think
about what Sophia was saying there is
this a genuine story or is it is it
click bait
I mean if oh six one half was the other
I think I suppose right to point out
that we need the houses to be built of
course and she's right to point that out
um I think it is a genuine concern
though that you know very often we hear
about you know uh plans uh where housing
developments are going to happen and
people and developers say that a set
amount will be set aside for
um uh social housing at which point then
if you're considering that 10 of the
people who are on the list aren't
necessarily from the UK and those
numbers are rising every year I can see
why politically it might be an issue for
a lot of people who might feel as though
they shouldn't be uh prioritized on the
list but as Spire says it's not so much
of an issue if nobody is getting into
the houses because that is in fact the
big the issue the block and I mean we
had um yesterday the uh Prince of Wales
uh gave an exclusive to the times where
he said that he was going to use uh the
duchy of cornwall's land to build social
housing he was talking about building
you know small but wanting to expand uh
this and I think it is something and
broadly speaking housing that is going
to come to Define I think a lot of
political arguments over the next decade
because it doesn't matter what it is if
it's starter homes for young
professionals if it's social housing if
it's temporary accommodation for
migrants it doesn't really matter what
it is we don't have it in any kind of
abundance dealing with that issue will
be crucial but the problem is and the
reason why it doesn't get done a lot of
Voters don't want it to happen near them
they're happy with the idea in general
just not near them and that's why houses
don't get built in this country because
people as much as they say that they
want immigrants they want people to get
on the housing ladder they want all of
these things they actually don't vote
for it when the push comes to show yes
which sort of leads us nicely on to our
next story which is on the front of the
Daily Telegraph because it involves
planning laws uh secure staff are giving
a big speech to fear tomorrow and the
telegraph saying that the current ban on
renewable energy source of onshore wind
farms would be lifted if labor get into
power
yeah another well this is a very very
sort of eye-catching
um policy from from labor and I think I
think this will go down really well with
some certainly young people I think this
will go down with he's going to scrap
the ban on you onshore uh wind farms um
and he says this is going to be his sort
of one of his first acts you know if he
makes it to number 10.
um and he's sort of vowing in this story
to throw everything at his net zero
agenda firing the starting gun on the
race to build more turbines across the
country and he's giving a big speech
tomorrow I think in Edinburgh it's
certainly in Scotland tomorrow and he's
going to sort of unveil you know Labor's
big big local power power plan sorry and
it's all part of his kind of clean
Mission I mean he's previously announced
um a sort of new publicly owned Clean
Energy company called GB energy and I
imagine this will all sort of feed into
that and he wants to get you know get
more solar panels on public land
um any sort of local communities to to
benefit from clean power
um it's interesting I mean more
generally I'm not sure you know how much
of a vote one of this stuff is
um but I think if they can make the case
that this is going to cut people's bills
and
um you know ease ease that kind of you
know bills at the end of the month and
the cost of living crisis I think that
might prick some ears actually
um I think I think labor has been in a
bit of a reframe it I think I've been
reframing their green policies at the
moment I think it'd be fair to say over
the past few weeks they've sort of toned
down a few pledges to sort of block oil
and gas development sort of saying that
you know we're not we're not going to
you know shut down existing fields or or
revoke current licenses or licenses
granted up to the general election and
they they sort of backtracked on a big
Earth it was 28 billion pounds sort of
green green scheme green Prosperity
scheme and so they have kind of been
rethinking some of their green policies
and dampening them down a little bit
Yeah okay um we're we're coming to the
end of the hour Benedict but quick
thought from you on this
yes I mean as with housing uh you can't
really have a sort of a functioning
economy one that wants to be
technologically advanced one that wants
to sort of move forward especially
outside of the European Union without
being self-sufficient in energy and that
energy being cheap we're uniquely
blessed in this country we could have uh
all the fossil fuels we want because
we've got them in oil gas and coal we
can have any number of nuclear power
stations that we want we have many
different sites for them and we have
ample amounts of space onshore and
offshore for wind farms this should be a
possibility again we don't do it because
people don't want it near them and that
is something that I think so here starma
and the labor party are going to have to
be honest with people and say we can
have an energy revolution in this
country we can be self-sufficient it can
be cheap we can even expert okay